[Musik]
jahr für jahr beginnen mehr als 100.000
menschen ein neues leben in der schweiz
was bringt sie dazu ihre heimat zu
verlassen und in der schweiz neu zu
beginnen und werden wie in der schweiz
ihr glück finden
wir haben menschen aus vier ländern bei
ihrem neuanfang in der schweiz begleitet
ich wollte eine neue lebensphase starten
seit einem jahr lebt lisa costa arosa in
graubünden
dieser stammt aus portugal
ihre kindheit verbrachte sie in
deutschland mit 18 ging sie zurück in
ihre heimat heirat zwei söhne inzwischen
erwachsen sind ist es zu bekommen dass
es mit der arbeit im ford war nicht sehr
gut ging und eigentlich waren meine
söhne auch schon in einem bestimmten
alter und dann hab ich gesagt das ist
die wendung ich hatte nichts zu
verlieren
[Musik]
juli und verbio kommen aus frankreich
er ist ingenieur die projektleiterin
in neuchâtel wollen sie ein neues leben
beginnen
wir waren auf der suche nach hoher
lebensqualität wenn möglich in einem
internationalen umfeld so kamen wir auch
die chance die natur war und wichtig
michael gefällt uns weil es eine
überschaubare stadt genau was wir
gesucht haben
[Musik]
wir waren wohl hier auf dem boot
die syrische familie als ace hat vor
zwei jahren in der schweiz asyl gefunden
das glückliche ende einer odyssee quer
durch afrika und über das mittelmeer
der bbl abakumowa es regnete in strömen
und das boot schaukelte hin und her
ich dachte wir müssten stärker als wir
dann das flugzeug gehört haben mussten
wir vor glück weinen und dann kann mir
nach lampedusa
das war ein wunder vor allem für die
kinder zumutbar ist ein erfolgreicher
manager aus neu delhi
er arbeitet für eines der größten
unternehmen in indien
nun soll er eine firma in der schweiz
leiten
das ist eine große chance für mich als
eine schweizer firma zu führen
es geht um neue technologien
das ist eine echte herausforderung für
mich alle sagen mir die ganze zeit du
gehst in ein fantastisches land dem
schiff handle das macht es natürlich
einfacher
[Musik]
[Applaus]
ich checke die verkehrslage auf meinem
smartphone das hilft mir ein wenig
schweizerisch zu sein
das heißt zb pünktlich bei meinen
meetings zu erscheinen
normalerweise habe ich einen fahrer das
hilft natürlich
heute jedoch ist seine frau mega mit dem
shop für unterwegs
das ist schwierig bei brot zum beispiel
heißt es dazu nicht gehe
das ist wirklich verwirrend ich denke
ich werde in der schweiz einen
sprachkurs besuchen müssen
[Musik]
der alltag dich hier alles andere als
schweizerisch ich verbringe jeden tag
bis zu drei stunden auto ich hatte eine
verschwendung von zeit und das ist etwas
was mir da nicht gefällt auch mega ist
managerin um ihrem mann in die schweiz
zu folgen gibt sie eine menge auf es
kann gut sein dass es nicht einfach wird
raúl wird viel arbeiten und unsere
tochter wird in der schule sein und ich
werde dann zu hause rumsitzen
ich hoffe dass ich in der schweiz
schnell einen job finden ansonsten freue
ich mich
sie ziehen in ein tolles lang werden in
einer schönen umgebung hohen und
ausführen haben
darauf freue ich mich
und heute habe ich in folge passiert
lisa lebt seit eineinhalb jahren in
graubünden in ilanz arbeitet sie in
einem alters- und pflegeheim in portugal
war sie in der textil branche
beschäftigt dann entlassung und
gelegenheitsjobs wenig geld um ihre
beiden söhne durchzubringen
ein neues leben mit 50 lieder entschied
sich für eine ausbildung im bereich
senioren flieger ist bereitet zum
beispiel die tapas für die bewohner dem
zimmer frühstück und sonst bin ich es
immer hier und schaue dass jeder das
bekommt was er mag
die genferin und pflegerin sind die
person die sie als erste sehen und das
ist für den auch irgendwie so ein
familiärer rhythmus weiter zeigt sind
gerne beim frühstück mit bewohner 60
grad wie sie aufgelegt zehnter morgen ob
sie gut geschlafen haben oder nicht da
bin ich wieder wie häufig in der schweiz
werden auch in graubünden in vielen
alten pflegeheimen eine große anzahl
arbeiten von ausländischen fachkräften
übernommen
du musst du so wie bei uns in der
putzete sind es vor allem portugiesen
eine italienerin die übrigen sind
schweizer
bei den pflegerinnen da sind auch viele
portugiesen
woher die anderen so kommen weiß er
nicht aber wir haben es gut miteinander
in der arbeit ist es immer wichtig gast
in jeder arbeit das dünne eine gute
menschliche verbindung hast das war mir
immer so jetzt langsam heimweh nicht wir
also mit denselben personen ja immer
gewohnt und jetzt habe ich einfach einen
einen weg gefunden um mit den kollegen
so umzugehen wie ich mich auch wohl
fühle und das haben sie jetzt auch schon
verstanden jetzt kennen die mich auch
schon und das geht ein bisschen so nach
meiner art auch ich muss ja auch
letztendlich auch in also ich kann
endlich seine andere sein
ich muss die sein die ich bin
kommt nicht ist er da
wanda ja wir sind immer hoch und runter
hoch und haben nichts mehr zu tun
[Gelächter]
den vormittag
schülerinnen hier noch nach mein name
renault okay nun gemeint sind gut bis
morgen halb acht danke messe wo man ein
gut eine besichtigung für morgen prima
jury und fabia sind auf der suche nach
einem appartements in der stadt zwei
zimmer 13 bis 4000 franken gibt es dann
auch ein paar fotos seit zwei monaten
arbeiten sie in der schweiz und suchen
eine wohnung die vermieter waren alle
ausländer kein einziger schweizer das
war jetzt ein franzose gestern genau
immer wenn wir wohnungen anschauen zehn
ausländer das war schon der zweite
irgendwas ist hier seltsam und keiner
sagt uns als improvisierte reicht jetzt
oder seit vier jahren sind die beiden
franzosen ein paar
fürs erste bleiben die beiden noch in
ihrer übergangswohnung bis sie das
appartements ihrer träume gefunden haben
im tessin steht familie als ich kurz
davor einen b ausweis zu bekommen
das ist üblich bei anerkannten
asylbewerbern für sie ein gefühl von
sicherheit
die als ex wohnen in einem sozialbau des
berühmten tessiner architekten mario
botta
seit zwei jahren leben in der schweiz
die kinder sind perfekt integriert und
gehen zur schule
[Musik]
einziger knackpunkt die 14-jährige
rasant in einer klasse von zehnjährigen
krieg und flucht haben sie mehrere
schuljahre gekostet jetzt holt sie nach
und spricht bereits fließend eine der
schweizer landessprachen sowie ihr meint
was richtig ist und den hammer
[Musik]
liebe mama bei dieser reise dachte ich
sie geht ans ende der welt
versuch mal dich in die geschichte
hinein zu denken
wie würdet ihr auch für schlecht
er hat keine ahnung wie es weitergehen
soll
willst du mal weiter rasant das boot
schaukelt das meer war aufgewühlt
wisst ihr was das heißt aufgewühlt
wütend dass mehrere voller wellen
kasamis beliebt sowohl bei ihren
mitschülerinnen wie bei den lehrern
[Musik]
dann ist erst 14 und hat in vielen
bereichen bereits die gedanken und die
reife einer erwachsenen frau
sie kümmert sich sehr lieb um ihre
mitschüler und strahlt sehr viel
positive energie aus wirklich geschafft
ihre schlimmen erfahrungen etwas
positives zu verwandeln
syrien ist größer als die schweiz
lass mich mal das hähnchen hinein
stecken
[Musik]
das arrangement von raul und mega in neu
delhi
in indien gehören sie zur oberschicht
dennoch wohnen sie zusammen mit raus
eltern in einer kleinen
vierzimmerwohnung das ist normal
genauso normal wie eine hausangestellte
zu haben
darauf wird mega in der schweiz
verzichten müssen
ich denke ich hole am besten eine nach
der anderen raus das lernt man ganz
schnell
davor habe ich am meisten angst dass
kochen
ich habe in meinem leben noch nie
gekocht und ich weiß wie anspruchsvoll
meinem mann in sachen apple und unsere
tochter auch dafür traf zumindest am
anfang
kochen ist einfach aber das aufräumen
das habe ich vergessen
man muss ja auch selber sauber machen du
kriegst vielleicht auch von aber erst
musst du alles auffressen
die drei generationen verbringen fast
ihre gesamte freizeit miteinander das
zusammenleben mit den eltern ist in
indien üblich und wird als vorteil
angesehen
dadurch dass eltern immer hier sind und
sich um unsere tochter kümmern kann ich
mich voll und ganz der arbeit und meiner
karriere widmen
das empfinde ich als große freiheit ohne
sie hätte ich jetzt beruflich niemals so
weit bringen könne
sie werden mir waren sie nicht fehlen
man muss seine kinder ziehen lassen
früher oder später fliegen sie auf den
mist machen karriere und leben ihr
eigenes liegen mit dem internet wird die
welt immer kleiner
distanzen haben nicht mehr so viel
bedeutung wie können sie doch jederzeit
besuchen wenn wir wollen europa ist ja
fast um die ecke
nur acht flugstunden das virgin-team für
rund mega ist es nicht die erste reise
in die schweiz pendelt seit mehreren
monaten hin und her um den großen sprung
vorzubereiten und vor fünf jahren
verbrachte das frisch verheiratete paar
seine ferien in der schweiz das war wie
die zweiten flitterwochen für uns die
schweiz fällt in indien zu den top
feriendestinationen so machten sich auch
mega und ruhe auf das land als touristen
zu entdecken
ich werde nie vergessen was wir in
zürich ankamen wir mussten ein paar
stationen mit dem tram fahren und dann
stand das tram vor uns und die türen
ging nicht auf
wir haben uns gefragt warum geht die tür
dann kam jemand und hat uns geholfen
wir mussten nur auf den roten knopf
drücken und die tür ging auf das war
ganz anders als bei uns
solche erinnerungen bleiben für immer
das wird spannend wir möchten ja auch
das land kennenlernen genf lugano
da gibt es eine menge zu sehen
außerdem haben wir gehört dass skifahren
in der schweiz seine tolle sache
das haben wir noch nie gemacht
vielleicht gehen wir auch dort auf die
piste und uns gleich alle knochen zu
brechen
das sieht ein bisschen aus wie bei uns
mit dach nischen wissen wie das erste
das sie angeschaut haben das quartier
gefällt mir schöner blick auf den see
eine wohnung mit balkon wäre toll oder
wenigstens einem garten
juli und fabia sind seit mehreren wochen
auf der suche nach einem arrangement sie
sind doppelverdiener und ihre ansprüche
lassen sich nicht leicht befriedigen
juli ist projektleiterin bei nestlé
vater ingenieur sie können sich etwas
leisten
vierter stock kein aufzug kein aufzug
[Applaus]
immerhin der beschwerliche aufstieg wird
belohnt
was sind denn das für kleine wittendorf
das ist ein hotel das wurde damals für
die expo gemacht das sieht man immer mal
wieder in reportagen über die schweiz
tolle aussicht und nahm wie gefriertruhe
eine solide und funktionellen absolut
sie werden dann ein gewisses einkommen
nachweisen müssen aufenthaltsgenehmigung
mit festem wohnsitz das wird schwierig
da beißt sich die katze in den schwanz
du bist auch franzose oder und warum
ziehst du ich verlasse die schweiz weil
ich in die usa vier haben sie schon
viele wohnungen besichtigt verarbeitet
in die kinos an
das würde ja passiert jetzt müssen wir
nur noch was wiederum die förderung
könnte auch eine option sein
[Musik]
alle gut hier gehen vielen deine war
viel glück
danke ich würde sagen nein ich auch die
vier etagen zu fuß das muss nicht sein
besonders nicht wenn man vom einkaufen
kommt wenn wir mal ein baby haben das
dann immer die treppen rauf tragen die
verlobten planen nachwuchs und sie
wollen heiraten
[Musik]
ein jahr lang hat leader in graubünden
hart gearbeitet
heute will sich einen traum erfüllen ein
eigenes auto in der schweiz nicht so gut
meinauto.de befindet sich fertig zum
radweg darum sich ein mann jo paladine
hilft sich raul luft gestoßen
mein ganzes leben lang auch wo ich
verheiratet sei das immer mein mann
gemacht so was mit dem autos was mache
ich jetzt ganz für mich mit meinem geld
also alles wirklich für mich und auch
ich war auch alles alleine muss man sich
selbst so viel geld brauchte zu stehen
gerne ich hab gedacht das hat man nur
mit kindern
ich war der bank um nach arbeitsschluss
5000 franken für das traumauto vom munde
abgespart 3000 kam sie in bar auf den
tisch legen den rest wird sie in kleinen
raten abzahlen
danke vielmals danke ihnen wenig
verlängern das irgendwie nein da bleiben
in der schweiz heilig ich weiß noch
nicht mal wenn man jetzt klappen jahr
heiß weiß man ja gar nicht lange bleibt
wird oder wie geht ihr das leben aber
irgendwie wenn du dir schon auch ein
auslands auch wenn ich das so mobil wie
es uns unabhängig
wie lange sie noch mit ihrer kritik
sehr stark in anrufen
[Musik]
für rohöl aus syrien steht ein
klassenausflug auf dem programm
zwei jahre nach ihrer ankunft beherrscht
sie bereit die sprache ihrer neuen
heimat das land entdeckte stets aufs
neue im tessin gefällt mir die stadt
lugano besonders die menschen
rabbanis bestens integriert sie hat
viele freundinnen freundinnen die doch
wann vergangenheit einen tiefen einblick
ins leben bekommen
ich weiß nicht viel über syrien nur das
ist dort krieg gibt und sie hier ihr
fliehen mussten
das ist nicht fair weil sie doch kinder
sind dort sind viele gestorben
aber gott sei dank hat sie es geschafft
und kann hier bei uns ein neues leben
beginnen in der schweiz fern des krieges
caravan mit ihren freundinnen ein ganz
normales teenagerleben führen bitte ich
auch wirklich raus klar drück ab
ich finde das war ein fantastisches
mädchen ist ich habe das gefühl sie mein
ganzes leben lang zu kennen
wir verbringen viel zeit miteinander und
ich habe ihr mit dem italienischen
häufig liest sehr tapfer
die neue heimat ist auch aus religiöser
sicht eine neue welt für die junge
muslimin zum ersten mal in ihrem leben
beträgt sie ein christliches gotteshaus
was erkennt ihr hier
das steht da richtig jesus stadt aller
frauen entdeckt die religion ihrer
christlichen freunde die wenig zu finden
die malereien sind wunderschön ich bin
muslimin für mich die christliche
religion sehr fremd aber es ist spannend
andere dinge kennenzulernen
ich würde jetzt nicht gerade meine
religion wechseln
aber es ist schön so was mal zu sehen
jury und serbien haben sich etliche
wohnungen angesehen und endlich eine
gefunden die ihren wünschen entspricht
die aufenthaltsgenehmigung gibt es hier
nicht doch hier gibt
mit ihrer neuen adresse wohnen sie nun
beim migrationsamt einen neuen anlauf
nehmen
du hast deinen ausweis nicht dabei daher
einmal der mietvertrag neben tausenden
grenzgängern leben auch circa 7000
franzosen ständig im kanton neuchâtel
wie lange wird es dauern bis wir die
aufenthaltsgenehmigung haben zwei wochen
sollen wir jetzt so dort später sie
bekommen eine rechnung dafür nicht
unsere sache kommt aus bern
nein diese kommt das match nach dem
papierkram bekommen juli und fabian noch
ein geschenk der besonderen art er noch
zwei gutscheine dafür bekommen sie
kostenlos jodtabletten in jeder apotheke
wir sind hier nur 50 kilometer vom
atomkraftwerk mühleberg entfernt das ist
eine besondere sicherheitszone falls mal
was schlimmes passiert aha im fall einer
katastrophe einfach zu hause aufbewahren
das wird alles im beipackzettel genau
erklärt ansonsten kann man das
ausführlich auf der webseite nachlesen
[Musik]
doch was wenn sie einen radio oder einen
fernseher haben müssen sie hier in der
schweiz rundfunkgebühren zahlen
das ist obligatorisch hier haben wir
noch einen gutschein
damit können wir das jahresabo für die
bahn günstiger kaufen
[Musik]
weiter geht es zum elektrizitätswerk
jetzt bräuchte ich ihren familiennamen
der not geboren zwölfte februar 1985
es geht da können wir uns in etwa sagen
womit wir monatlich rechnen müssen
wir haben ehrlich gesagt keine ahnung
das sieht man auf der alten
stromrechnung also die anzahlung beträgt
in ihrem fall 60 franken
alle zwei monate genau alles klar
danke und einen schönen tag noch
[Musik]
langsam dämmert es den franzosen dass
sie sich für ihr neues leben kein
günstiges pflaster ausgesucht haben
die kaution müssen wir auch noch fahren
das erscheint mir ziemlich viel da
bleibt nicht viel übrig wenn man die
versicherungen um elektrizität ums
internet abzieht
das wollen hier suchen wo wir ausgehen
können gehen wir zusammen suche und lisa
beendet einen ausbildungskurs des roten
kreuzes 35 tage lang hatte den kurs
besucht neben ihrer arbeit
die kosten dafür hatte sich von ihrem
mageren einkommen ab gespart
das war wirklich so anstrengen 100% zu
arbeiten und dann noch hier nach noch
kurz kommen das ist acht stunden hier
sitzen dann bin ich halt nicht mehr
gewohnt in der schule habe ich hier
erlebt ich hab ich den aktiven
es ist der letzte kurs tag die meisten
frauen hier kommen aus dem ausland und
möchten in der schweiz arbeiten
[Musik]
und was schön und unter kurze zeit
insofern für mich wichtig dass ich mich
jetzt auch nicht nur eine arbeit bin ich
gern hast und dann ich bin auch
validiert nach der kurzen zeremonie
haben die frauen noch zeit sich
untereinander auszutauschen
viele von ihnen müssen nicht nur ihre
kinder sondern auch noch ihre eltern
finanziell versorgen
[Musik]
meine mutter etwas gesagt was hier
gesagt wenn du mich in einem rein steckt
ein sterben
manchmal denke ich ich muss mich ich
muss im alter bei meiner mutter dabei
sein
[Musik]
ein fitnesstraining für heute
bei den franzosen steht der umzug an
endlich ein zuhause in der schweiz das
ist jetzt unser zuhause
mit blick aufs schloss ohne die alpen
unser zuhause
vor der schweiz lebten sie drei jahre
lang in schweden nur nachgeordnet ist
noch alles auf schwedisch
die wollten mich zurück nach frankreich
gebaut
wir dachten uns hier in der schweiz
hatten wir das öfter aus schweden und
das beste aus frankreich verein also
besetzt haben wir hier ein tolles leben
ein strafzins
machen wir doch ein foto um ihren chef
zu zeigen dass sie nichts verkehrt
gemacht haben ein erster kulturschock in
der schweiz müsste in diesem fall die
polizei über den umzug informiert werden
nun wartet eine saftige busse auf die
umzugsfirma
was nervt mich mich auch was wir denn
machen
man sieht doch dass dazu ein umzug ist
wird das kosten 120 punkten
hoffentlich zeit dass der ja das sollte
ihre firma zahlen
wo ist unser name wie bitte ich musste
ihn unter briefkasten
keine werbung warum ich mag sowieso
keine werbung
heute hatten wir trotzdem welche das ist
nicht zum drauf liegen
ich schaue dich ob du das aufbauen will
dabei willst du dich nur drauf legen
jetzt sind wir seit zweieinhalb monaten
ständig hin und her gezogen
manchmal waren wir einen monat lang an
einem ort aber oft war mir auch nur für
ein paar nächte in einer wohnung mit
seinen siebensachen die ganze zeit hin
und her zu ziehen das macht dann fertig
in den letzten zwei monaten haben wir in
13 verschiedenen becken geschlagen
jetzt heißt es auspacken aber das hier
vor weihnachten einen christbaumständer
weiß gar nicht ob man hier so bäume
aufstellten
ich denke schon
mohammed hatte zwei herzinfarkte schwere
arbeiten kommen für ihn nicht mehr in
frage
in der schweiz lebt die familie von
sozialhilfe seinen sozialen status hat
mohammed auf der flucht verloren alle
hasler mit einer kette turia in syrien
da war ich in leipzig hatte eine arbeit
in einem großen unternehmen
ich hatte dort eine gute stelle in
syrien ging es uns allen gut
auch finanziell wir hatten ein gutes
leben
ja und dann gingen die proteste los die
leute gingen auf die straße und die
soldaten der regierung von oft alles
geschossen was sich bewegt auch auf mich
eine kugel der soldaten hat mich
getroffen
sie gehen quer durch die wangen
sie hat mir fast das gesicht zerstört
sie gingen hier rein und auf der anderen
seite wieder raus das hat mir die ganzen
zähne kaputt gemacht ich musste zweimal
operiert werden
das war dann der moment dass sie
beschlossen haben aus holz zu fliehen
[Musik]
in der schweiz findet mohammed trost und
unterstützung in der religion wenn er
aus seiner wohnung geht dann vor allem
zum freitagsgebet in einer moschee in
die asse doch heute ist schwierig mit
den schweizer verkehrsmitteln
hallo wir haben den bus verpasst
leider sind die hier immer so pünktlich
könnte uns vielleicht jemand abholen und
zum skifahren die flüchtlinge helfen
sich untereinander
es dauert nicht lange und die beiden
werden abgeholt von einer ihrer charta
reck floh vor 20 jahren
seither lebt er in der schweiz
kennengelernt haben sie sich über die
flüchtlingshilfe heute sind sie freunde
new york heute tritt ein gesetz in kraft
das ist den frauen verbietet sich
vollständig zu verschleiern
nun die schweizer kennen ihre gesetze
machen wie sie wollen
aber findest du gerecht dass sie das
verbietet gerät ich weiß nich jeder
sollte so machen dürfen wir will das
wäre gerecht
[Musik]
die frauen sind zu hause geblieben auch
sie reden über das gleiche thema ich
habe schon immer kopftuch getragen aber
komplett verhüllen möchte ich mich nicht
davor jeder machen wie er will
aber für mich wäre das nichts so
komplett verhüllt sie muss sich nicht
verhehlen ich bin muslimin und ich mag
es kopftuch zu tragen
das ist gut so ich mag das einfach nicht
ich werde kein kopftuch tragen später
sicher nicht
[Musik]
in wenigen tagen der trauer in die
schweiz reisen
zusammen mit seiner frau mega und
tochter dia nimmt er an einer putscher
einer religiösen haus
einweihungszeremonie teil des
appartements gehört megas bruder und
befindet sich im nobel-vorort ghoga die
zeremonie findet in sanskrit stadt auch
wenn das nur einer der anwesenden
verstehen
der priester genauso wie gerieten die
vollzogen werden
ja gibt viele rauchmelder nein das war
das erste was der priester gefragt hat
in der schweiz werden wir solche reden
sicherlich nicht in dieser art leben
können das werden wir bestimmt vermissen
für uns sind das momente die uns viel
bedeuten
traditionen sind wichtig sie helfen uns
unsere wurzeln nicht zu verlieren
[Musik]
vielleicht verstehen wir nicht immer
alles was wir hier machen aber wir
wissen dass uns und unsere familien
etwas gutes erwartet wenn wir ihnen
folgen
wir stehen vor großen herausforderungen
jede generation verliert ein wenig mehr
den weg zurück zu den traditionen auch
ich und meine familie glichen sie haben
mich vorhin gefragt was wir da genau
machen
und ganz ehrlich ich weiß es nicht wir
folgen einfach den priester so was
müssen wir in zürich auch machen aber
eine art mini version
und das passiert in der nächsten folge
von graz die schweiz die einwanderer
[Musik]
viva fiebert zusammen mit den
portugiesen bei der fußball
europameisterschaft
trotzdem fühlte sich einsam ihre söhne
und ihre mutter fehlen ihr lisa
einschließlich sie in portugal zu
besuchen
[Musik]
die familie als begeht den ramadan war
anschließend brechen rahman und rasern
auf ins erste ferienlager ihres lebens
das ist meine freundin vivian ja ferien
aus aleppo und wohnt bei uns um die ecke
[Musik]
los geht's rabia entdecken die schweizer
natur
sind kann man ja fakturieren und
beginnen einen neuen lebensabschnitt in
neu delhi feiern mega und raul ihren
aufbruch in die schweiz mit der familie
ich habe eine bekannte in genf sie sagt
es sei relativ lang malerin das stimmt
raúl wird sich zunächst alleine auf den
weg machen und alles vorbereiten
eine zeit der trennung von frau und
familie steht an
[Musik]